List of things that make men instantly more hot
starting off with No. 1 rolled up sleeves
those forearms
those veins, the muscles
HOT!
No. 2 when men are oblivious to how hot they are
I don't know why
but when men are oblivious to their hotness
it's an instant panty dropper
No. 3 five o'clock shadow
okay this is personal preference
but a little scruff just gets me going
No. 4 if they're able to have witty banter
there's nothing worse than trying to have some banter with someone
and they're just a brick wall
If a man is a brick wall that just instantly makes him less attractive
No. 5 when a man smells like a man
not necessarily Cologne
but just their natural pheromones
sometimes Cologne can be too much and too overpowering
but when he smells clean, fresh clothes
freshly washed clothes and just their natural man scent
panty dropper instantly more attractive
No. 6 when he only has eyes for you
he's not checking out any other ladies around you
if you're on dates
he's not breaking his neck
he's only looking at you
No. seven
what instantly makes a man more attractive is when he says your name
There’s just some powerful thing about it
when a man says your name
it's hot
No 8 when a man loves your pet instantly
when he talks to your pets in a cute little voice
I don't know why
but that just instantly makes men hotter
lastly when men put their hand the small of your back when you're walking
instantly makes men more powerful and just more attractive
like yes
heard me baby
heard me like I'm your sheep